great people don't give up live up to
the challenges that life throws at them
if you do not enjoy the process if you
do not enjoy the day-to-day work of
actually doing the thing that you do
everyday you will lose that it's okay
this is my number one way of how to find
strength in difficult times is reminding
yourself that the way you feel is okay
rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I want
to see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
see challenges as opportunities over you
go or Gopal das December 10th 1940 there
was a massive explosion in West Orange
New Jersey United States of America ten
buildings in a factory owned by the
legendary inventor Thomas Edison were
engulfed by flames six to eight fire
departments rushed to the scene but
could not curb the chemical fueled
inferno after having tried all that he
could as Thomas Edison calmly stood
there watching the fire destroy his
entire lives
work his twenty four-year-old son
Charles came over and stood next to him
in a childlike voice Edison said to his
son Charlie go and get your mother and
her friends they'd never be able to see
a spectacular fire like this in their
entire life astonished and shocked by
father's response Charles asked Thomas
Edison our entire Factory is being burnt
down to ashes bed Thomas Edison replied
in complete composure yes
our factory is being burnt down to ashes
but all the mistakes we have made so far
in the factory have also been burnt down
to ashes we will start all over again
tomorrow that evening Thomas Edison told
a New York Times reporter although I'm
67 years old and I'm completely
exhausted from running around and trying
to control the file
tomorrow I'll start all over again
afresh and so he did the next day was a
fresh beginning for Thomas Edison and
his son Charles and trying to rebuild
what had been destroyed by the fire
often this is what life does unto us our
dreams are shattered our hopes
broken efforts baffled great people they
don't cry they try to rebuild their
dreams great people don't give up live
up to the challenges that life throws at
them great people don't go through they
grow through the difficulties that come
on their path they start all over again
with great hope with great determination
with great grit and that is why they
reach the highest peaks of success that
most people only aspire for that is why
I say no challenges no success no
challenges no success so first off man I
loved our Gopal das he tells amazing
stories has amazing lessons and also
Thomas Edison what about acid 67 to have
that mindset I just wonder when I hear
these stories I wonder how I would react
I think I would react in a similar way I
don't know if it would be my default
reaction that my building is on fire
come and look at this beautiful flavors
it's destroying everything around me the
core lesson I take away though from this
is you have to enjoy the process so many
people when they are starting the
business or just think you're not with
your life with your goals you're chasing
these milestones I want to build a huge
factory I want to get a million
subscribers I want to hit a million
dollars of revenue you're chasing
milestones but
don't like the work were the most
successful people in the world they love
the process you love the work you love
getting up and doing the thing I love
making videos I love helping
entrepreneurs I love it I love it I love
it I love it it's what I read to do I
could do it all day long and all of the
benefits come from that and it build a
business around it and get the accolades
and get the awards but it all stems from
the origination point of loving the
craft where too many people wake up and
they drive to a job that they hate and
they have arbitrary goals that don't
really mean much to them and they don't
want to do the work to get there it's
not let's set some goal and say I'm
going to do anything it takes to get
there because you won't if you don't
love the process you won't win because
the people who love the process will
always crush you the person who on
YouTube wants to hit a million
subscribers versus the person who loves
making video content for their audience
this person who loves the content is
going to hit a million plus the person
is just trying to hit a million we'll
never get there that's the main thesis
and for Thomas Edison yes of course the
building burning down is is not what
what he would have hoped for but it's
not as big a deal for him because he
still gets to invent the process for him
was waking up and inventing every day
that's what he wants to do and now he
gets to do it in a new building that
isn't gonna create sometimes I secretly
hope that my youtube channel will blow
up not blow up huge or blow up like blow
down set the YouTube channel on fire and
start all over again it's this little
secret wish for mine I don't actually
wanted to happen because of the people I
have on my team right that there's eight
people who work on my YouTube team and
that's jobs that are gone if my youtube
channel burns to the ground but the idea
of certain over the idea of building
fresh from the ground is really
intoxicating and so I don't do it on the
YouTube channel I do it on separate
YouTube channels I have a French channel
I'm stardom I have a Spanish team
starting Instagram I'm certain up we
just passed 10,000 followers Instagram
was my latest obsession besides YouTube
because I love the startup process
I love grinding and figure things out
and understanding the algorithm and
understanding how to win and figuring
out the methodology where YouTube now
what I'm doing is really mature and yes
there's still innovations that are
happening but it's not the same thing as
as the startup and so I think it's just
so important that you understand you
need to love the process you need to
love the work that you are doing you
need to be the best at that work and
wake up yes with goals to go and get a
million dollars and whatever your big
goals in life are those are so important
the goals can be motivating to help
drive you forward especially when things
are tough you've had a bad day a bad
week a bad couple of months like your
big vision your big goals can really
help you but if you do not enjoy the
process if you do not enjoy the
day-to-day work of actually doing the
thing that you do everyday you will lose
because you can only force yourself to
do something that you hate for so long
before you quit I challenge you to study
any of your heroes any people that you
look up to whoever your biggest mentors
are in life and business and athletics
whoever your heroes are the people who
you look at and say these people achieve
the pinnacle of success they've done
what I want to do I guarantee you they
love the work they love the process they
love doing the thing that they are doing
every day and that's why they now I've
got a very special bonus clip for you
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that question the day I want
to know if your building was on fire
that you spent 50 years building or
Edison maybe 30 years building and this
on fire would you stand there and say
come watch the flame or not what would
your reaction be leaving the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
this prey so give me go
you have to remind yourself that it's
okay to feel the way you feel when
you're going for a difficult time it's
okay to feel weak it's okay to want to
cry it's okay to feel overwhelmed just
reminding yourself that it's okay this
is my number one way of how to find
strength in difficult times is reminding
yourself that the way you feel is okay
to honor that feeling to accept that
feeling to actually be okay with that
what we see or what we perceive to be a
weakness or what we perceive to let us
down or what we perceive is a sign of
you know instability or insecurity we've
got to remind ourselves that when things
are tough it's okay to feel that way
there's nothing wrong with that any
difficulty I go to I look to moments in
history where people have enjoyed the
same pain
if not more extreme and analyze absorb
and connect with how they got through it
I like to see what they were thinking I
like to see what they did I like to see
how they structured themselves I like to
look at how they organized I looked like
to look at who they were speaking to I
like to look at what was going through
their mind at that time because you've
got to remember that any challenge we're
facing today we've faced it before as as
humanity right beyond ethnicities beyond
color race creed beyond backgrounds
beyond all walks of life as human beings
we've been through challenges before and
we've got through them and therefore
reconnecting with how that's been done
before is a beautiful way of learning
how to overcome current challenges so
you can either look at your past but
real wisdom lies in looking at the past
of people who made a difference you look
at people like Martin Luther King you
look at people like Gandhi you look at
people who made world-changing
differences not single-handedly but
influenced from a single perspective
from a single point of view and really
connecting with the powerful moments in
history now I've said this quote many
times I've read it many times and this
quote actually is is unbelievable and
the quote says that they fought they
buried us they
no we were seeds right it's a Mexican
proverb they thought they borrowed us
they didn't know we were seeds and I was
thinking these when you tell yourself
that story
you start thinking much more differently
right a seed is buried - it's incredible
that the seed goes through the same
process as anything else it's put deep
underground right all of this mud is put
on top of it it gets rained on it gets
snowed on all these kind of things but
it knows that it's a seed so it knows
that it can grow so there anything's
possible and it grows through and you
see even plants growing through concrete
sometimes right it's unbelievable how
much power a seed has so changing the
stories we tell ourselves we can either
look at challenging situations as
opportunities for growth as an
opportunity to learn as an opportunity
to change be the change we can look at
them and and really fool down now that
that second part is okay we can even
feel like that right but we have to
recognize it's not permanent
we've gotta accept that none of our
feelings are permanent they don't need
to be permanent it's a choice so if you
need to vent vent I was saying to
someone yesterday if you need a vent
vent if you need to run run if you need
to complain complain if you need to
share if you do that but recognize that
those feelings are not permanent and
it'll be amazing when we've realized we
are seeds right that is the most
powerful way of finding strength raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
something serene I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details